bueno estamos en una situación muy
complicada y efectivamente como usted
dice el talibán está nuevamente en el
poder y esto no es una situación que
agrade a nadie y la verdad que se
ingresó a esa guerra para quitar los
nexos entre el talibán y al-qaeda y eso
efectivamente logró romperse hasta
cierto punto pero la situación hoy es
sumamente compleja los talibanes han
regresado y han regresado de la mano de
estados unidos que finalmente admiten no
poder controlar la situación en el
territorio esta es la realidad y los
talibanes se supone que se van a
comportar de manera distinta de lo que
lo han hecho en hasta hace dos décadas
anteriores los primeros indicios que
tenemos son contradictorios porque si
bien los mensajes que dicen o que emiten
que intentan transmitir tranquilidad la
realidad es que en la práctica tenemos
una situación muy distinta y no sabemos
muy bien motivo del temor que tiene la
población que está huyendo y algunas
versiones no confirmadas aunque algunas
si le permiten darle credibilidad
no han cambiado su actitud y son
terriblemente discriminatorios en
relación a la mujer de hecho dicen que
las mujeres no van a tener problemas con
las mujeres sin embargo al mismo tiempo
están recomendando a las mujeres no
salir a la calle porque ellos no pueden
asegurar que todos los talibanes sepan
cómo manejarse frente a las mujeres hoy
esto no claramente es un problema
precisamente por ahí quería preguntarle
la población civil especialmente niños y
mujeres están en riesgo sus derechos
humanos y sus vidas amenazadas por la
imposición de un islam que se prevé
radical pese a los discursos que ustedes
bien dice se han mostrado moderados que
le espera al pueblo afgano
bueno no sabemos que le espera el pueblo
afgano no aparentemente nada bueno la
realidad es que las escenas que vemos en
la calle con hombres talibanes armados
hasta los dientes azotando a las mujeres
y a cualquiera que no se comporte de
manera adecuada no es una buena señal y
las mujeres están huyendo del país una
de las principales en coronas
principales periodistas de la televisora
afgana ha abandonado el país en el día
de ayer a pesar de que se les dieron
supuestas garantías de que iba a poder
trabajar sin embargo ha sido desplazada
de su noticiero
y eso indica que hay que definitivamente
va a haber problemas con este tema y hay
una crisis migratoria en ciernes esto
está claro recordemos que organizan es
un país multiétnico en la nación no
respeta no coincide con el estado es un
estado multiétnico y hay una etnia
predominante que es la pastún que está
digamos dividida entre pakistán y
afganistán y eso pone en el escenario
también a pakistán que por cierto
también teme que el talibán dentro de su
propio territorio se convierta en un
problema por un lado y por otro lado hay
una facción del issys que está operando
que aparte es parte de la interna
digamos pastor que está en el poder
actualmente
mayoritariamente los talibanes son
pastunes no todos pero graba una buena
mayoría